preview for death is the enemy on the
other hand seems to be suggesting that
there is a possibility of genji getting
killed in the very next episode if you
pay attention to this brief shot of the
hound crushing the skull of a white you
would notice that he is building genji's
hammer if you are wondering how am i so
sure that this particular hammer is the
one that belongs to gendry it's actually
pretty simple the last episode ended
with jon snow leading a raiding party in
order to be on the wall as we can see
the only one that is building hammer is
genji while everyone else including the
hound are building swords additionally
there's a shot from the preview of the
next episode in which the hound is
clearly holding a sword to summit up
sander is wielding a sword but will for
whatever reason exchange it for ginger's
camera at some point with this being
said let's see if the preview for the
sixth episode just confirmed gendry's
death we see the excursion traveling
through the lands beyond the wall trying
to follow the vision the hound sowing
the flames they finally see the mountain
shaped like an arrowhead which is when a
large blizzard starts and jon and his
team are being attacked by a horde of
wights they basically run into the army
of the dead this is when jon battles
white walker one on one giving an
opportunity to genji and the rest of the
team to capture white but it's way too
hard as the other whites also attack at
the same time once the white army
attacks seoul at once john and his team
see that the only thing they can do is
run which is also the last time gendry
is being seen
later on after they run for a while they
eventually end up being stuck in the
middle of the lake on a large piece of
ice that floats above the other smaller
pieces of ice john and his team cannot
do anything but to basically wait for
the lake to freeze and for the army of
the dead to attack them all of them are
being together all but gingery
eventually the lake has finally refrozen
and the horde rashes said jon and his
team they run but end up fighting the
most important part in this particular
fight is the hound building ginger's
hammer which could mean that ginger is
at this point already killed by the army
of the dead even though sandra crushing
the skull of a bite with gingerous
hammer obviously implicates that ginger
is weaponless it does not necessarily
mean that ginger is already been killed
a few days ago i brought you a video in
which i introduced you with the leaks
regarding the sixth episode those same
leaks might have provided us more
accurate answer on a question regarding
injuries fate before i go any further
let me just say that those leaks seem to
be quite accurate so if you don't want
anything spoiled it's time for you to
close this video anyways there stated
that genji will not get killed but will
rather be commanded by jon to run back
to eastwatch and send a raven to dany to
come and rescue them this would explain
why the hound is building injury's
hammer as it would only slow down gendry
taking into account how accurate those
leaks have been so far and also taking
into account that gingrich has just
reappeared i think it's safe to say that
genji will not get killed just yet